j'étais d'abord assez surpris que l'on
me choisisse pour ses trousses et de la
reconnaissance parce qu'en réalité vous
savez quand on fait ce métier de
journalisme du journaliste vous savez
firmament ça semble tout naturel tout ce
raffut donc parler de reconnaissance ça
part un peu surprenant bon il est
évident que ça fait plaisir pour son
niveau mais ainsi que je les dis je j'ai
bien aimé dédier ce trophée à une autre
journaliste un confrère
je parlais de milliers d'oies qui
qui a été à mon sens le premier
journaliste authentiquement martiniquais
qui a sévi sur les antennes de radio
martinique pas ce plus qui est
intéressant c'est que
on se rend compte malgré les
individualismes la mémoire collective
gargan trop quelque chose est fait a pas
m à cause de tensions
ce que certains ont pu faire par le
passé et qui perdure en disant espérons
leur était très émue d avance à plus de
reconnaissance décernée par le club
presse c'est un grand honneur pour moi
je suis très contente
vous attendiez à une telle
reconnaissance au coup de projecteur je
ne m'attendais pas du tout à ce coup de
projecteur
c'est une belle initiative de portée
nous reconnaissance envers les anciens
est votre regard sur la presse
d'aujourd'hui la pression aujourd'hui
nous elle est jeune elle est là beaucoup
d'efforts encore à faire et comme je
disais tout à l'heure un confrère il
faut qu'elle garde il faut qu'elle ait
un peu de rigueur dans dans le métier
fauqué plus de rigueur dans le métier
sinon bon elle va se former comme moi je
me suis formé